boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on
really excited to still be on-site at
Ben Boston in Cambridge Massachusetts
we are still at MIT the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and we are going
to be talking about all things open
learning all things RFID sensors
automation the future of work digital
learning university designed so much we
have the honor of sitting down with dr.
Sanjay Sarma thank you so much for
coming out to the show it's great
pleasure initiating huge shout out to
many flowers for introducing such a
wonderful man
yes mentor and mentor totally totally
big shout out to first robotics and
Sanjay your background is so interesting
okay so either if you're Fred and Daniel
for flowers professor of mechanical
engineering at MIT he co-founded the
auto ID Center at MIT is the vice
president for open learning at MIT which
includes the office of digital learning
mi t--'s integrated learning initiative
in the Abdul Latif Jameel world
education lab he's on the board of EDX
as well which is a non profit company
that delivers MOOC founded by Harvard
and MIT so holy cow the amount of of
being at the cutting edge of how people
learn in the world is just is you're
right there you're right there and you
guys here you have a hundred fifty
person open learning floor here and how
are we gonna educate the next generation
of kids into our world this is what a
lot of what you guys do as well as at
the adult level so let's um let's start
with let's start with you know who you
are and how you got here because I think
I think a lot of times we don't really
see the full big history picture of
things and you are right there on the
civilizational evolution scale of things
because the way you speak you speak
about these architectures changing that
we had transit shifts with cars and
planes and that helped with moving
around we have the internet and cell
phone shift we have this artificial
intelligence shift that are coming and I
love that big history perspective so
tell us about how you got that awareness
shift
yourself and got interested in doing
this doing the open learning stuff yeah
oh yeah you know I I'm an engineer
and what engineers do we see an
opportunity we exploit it right and so
that's what I did with RFID and other
fields Internet of Things etc but as as
a student I always felt that my
experience was very passive but I
learned when I was active I learned when
I was designing things if if what I was
designing something and I needed
thermodynamics I'd really understood
thermodynamics but if I was sitting here
passively and someone's tell me about
thermodynamics the absorption wasn't
great the mind is active you learn the
minds just listening mode it fills up
very quickly you know so I had a been my
bonnet about it and come to MIT was
great because now I was in the invention
mode
research mode and you know it was really
great for me so when the opportunity
came to help MIT in the setting up of
the new University in Singapore I got
involved with that and one our former
dean became the president I led the MIT
team and I really got into learning that
way and then I began to see the
opportunities and that was a you know in
the 2010 timeframe and it be stir MIT
started thinking about online education
using things like MIT xix etc etc and I
got bitten by the bug and there was you
know so the president asked me to do
take over the whole digital enterprise
from a learning perspective it was there
was no way I could not do it I love how
you illustrate the difference between
reading and learning from a textbook
versus this necessity or curious
curiosity there's a drive to learn
experientially there's a big difference
in a way that we retain and actually get
our awareness expanded through that and
also I'm glad that that the MIT is
taking this major initiative in digital
learning across the world now and that
you're spearheading that now how does
how does this transition because you
also have authored a book about this as
well we're kind of
Anning in a way of seeing things that is
no longer trying to maybe do some barely
incremental changes fit a product into
something that customers want your we're
talking like a major shift in with the
way that we rebuild technologies and
products and services that fill the way
that civilization sort of evolving tell
us a bit about your framework for seeing
the world in that in that way yeah I'm
writing a book I haven't finished it yet
but with the colleague but the the thing
about there was a very magical time in
in the history of humankind technologies
become so powerful that imagine the
imagination as the limit it's not a
technology anymore right
and if you look at for example something
like a cell phone a smartphone I
remember about 30 years ago as just my
wife and I then girlfriend we're going
to meet somewhere and then we had to say
I will meet you at Trafalgar Square
Square at 10 a.m. in London on that date
and we both had to show up does the only
way you could meet and if you didn't
show up there's no recourse and now we
take it for granted we have smartphones
and everything's changed our payments of
change the way we order a taxi string
everything's changed so this is true of
a number of things around us it's crept
up on us but it's transformational and
education has to go through that and
sometimes I will make the argument it is
easier to make a bigger change than a
smaller change interesting right it's
almost easier to just rethink it and
redo it change completely
yes then to go half way because you're
neither here nor there you you want to
be beyond the tipping point kind of like
where as we see technology sometimes
being leap frogged yeah like we don't
need a home phone network anymore that's
right about being place we've jumped
straight to the self yeah I mean I grew
up in India you know it was very hard to
get a land telephone line and now
everyone has a smart phone and no one
had you know then a lot of people never
had a land land line their families
never had a land line and they went
straight to smart phones right so we so
it's almost like you need to sort of see
a vision and just go there and not not
even care about the waypoints in between
so what's happening is that because of
all the tectonic changes in our in our
society where
the gig economy it's you know people
freelancing people working remotely
people working multiple jobs people
having to transition from one job to
another technologies half-lives have
changed if you know technology today for
example the technology using to shoot
the video here in three years is gonna
be completely different we have to
constantly learn learning isn't
something you do for four years and
you're out you're you are going to be in
a learning state of mind forever it's
like you're on a treadmill the trembling
is blowing backwards so if you're not
you're unning forward you're gonna fall
off that means and that can happen on
campus it's gonna happen online it's
gonna happen with video and audio on
podcast and maybe virtual reality who
knows but that's how it's gonna happen
so you might as well embrace the future
go there and have the rest follow this
this way of seeing lifelong learning
being on a treadmill is so good because
we see so often that the more that we
invest our time into the cutting edge of
knowledge over and over again we have
the conscious choice every day when we
come home am I going to watch something
that's just gonna distract me or am I
gonna watch one of the world leaders in
their field give a talk yeah yep and if
we continue down that path we keep
educating ourselves at the edge and that
just takes us to a newer and newer level
of abstract thinking and creativity
around where things are going and how we
can stay at the front I like that a lot
now and I really appreciate your big
picture understanding of the evolution
of technology in the world so okay so
now tell us about the Radio Frequency
Identification RFID this is super
interesting how you had a way of of
pioneering that technology and now
that's exploding into IOT so yeah tell
tell us about this you know about 20
years ago a group of us me a gentleman
by the name of Kevin Ashton David Brock
Sonny soo there were a whole bunch of us
three or four of us we started this
thing
the Auto ID Center and we have the crazy
idea of replacing barcodes effectively
with radiofrequency ID and you know
you've all seen RFID RFID use it into a
toll pass this RFID and the problem is
RFID tags at the time just cost to like
Twain and still do if you buy toll pass
you know those plastic a little little
rectangular boxes they cost about twenty
bucks fifteen bucks Amir that and we had
the crazy idea that if we rethought it
fundamentally they would become a few
cents and that's what's come to pass now
and so to do that we had to pull
together a technology roadmap rethink
the way that technology worked
we had to anticipate the cloud the cloud
didn't exist them so we had to
anticipate the cloud I would point at
this sky and I didn't have the word
clouds that said the sky the internet
you know and we put together a bunch of
protocols with about a hundred really
amazing companies large companies like
Walmart and J&J and Tesco and Proctor
and Gamble and tiny companies some of
them didn't survive but many of them are
successful startups and successful big
companies now right and we put together
a movement I became a new standard there
were prototypes they were industry
adoption sort of efforts pilots and now
you know if you go to a lot and tailors
and Macy's at dekat long as Zara you're
gonna see these RFID tags being used
everywhere it's called the electronic
product code and what it did was very
simple the fact of the matter is the
supply chain you know whether it's
manufacturing in a faraway country or
sales in a retail store today or before
RFID you had very little idea of the
inventory yeah where are those clothes
do I have the right size of jeans out
there and suddenly now those things
could tell you and now your inventory is
automated and that changes the
effectiveness of the supply chain and
that's how it took off and they were
probably about 10 billion RFID tags last
year whoa how did you guys get the cost
down from 15 or 20 bucks to a couple
cents very interesting this is again
it's one of those tipping point things
RFID was caught in a sort of a paradigm
lock which was they were doing too much
so RFID tags they would write data into
the tag and so you needed memory right
if you needed to write data into the tag
it needed more power a regular RFID the
stuff we do is passive it has no battery
so it actually scavengers power from the
reader right so but then if it needs a
lot of power you can't go very far so
what we said was listen
the Internet's taking off so just put a
unique number on the tag license plate
and put all the data on the network and
people don't feel crazy because they
didn't believe the internet was taking
of 1998 people didn't even know the
internet was but we made that bet and
then we just focused on simplifying the
tag and the protocol making the protocol
really efficient again there are lots of
companies involved of amazing capital
from amazing people from all these
companies and of course the MIT crew
University of Cambridge in the UK you
know city of Adelaide Fudan University
in China and ETF Zurich those are the
universities he brought into the loop
and we all work together and once we
went to this new world where the data
would be in the sky because I can say
cloud because that notion the didn't the
world didn't exist and you could make
the tags cheap it's very tiny and
low-power you just took off and then
once the paradigm said in industry took
off
interesting and they could be that small
because they would scavenge the power
from the source that's aiming to scan it
well the the tag consists of a chip and
an antenna right the antenna is bigger
but you can put in the packaging for
example a the chip itself is about one
third of a millimeter and because the
chip is small it needs very little power
yeah
it turns out not to get your technical
that if you put a lot of functionality
on the chip and the chip becomes big it
needs more power yeah whoa so ten
billion are at least you're at least
yeah and and it's everywhere in the
supply chain because it makes inventory
so much easier and this is actually a
big deal with
with the way that we're advancing
blockchain protocols as we care a lot
about making sure that it's a
trust-based thing as well we want to
make sure that these that the right item
is being processed and we're following
it along the track but also by the way
toll passes those irritating big
rectangular plastic boxes they're gonna
be really replaced with our standard
soon so yeah whoa
okay now the auto ID lab is exploding
into IOT as well so teach us about
what's going on
with the auto ID lab sighs whoo that
what kind of a composition of like
engineers scientists are there and then
what's going on with IOT transition yeah
so the term IOT was actually coined by
one of the cofounders of the auto idea
lab kevin Ashton and what he said was
you know what we were all saying at that
time was everything's gonna be connected
to the Internet I would point at a clock
and say someday that'll be connected to
the internet people thought I was crazy
but that's basically what my Apple watch
is right yeah so and so that term IOT
which Kevin came up with this really
captured the zeitgeist in 2005 time
frame it started taking off we wrote a
paper in in the late 1990s early 2000s
called a networked physical world which
sort of talked about it now
IOT is very interesting so why do we
connect things to the Internet
because you can do amazing things with
it
so for example if I have a camera
outside my home and my lock is on is
connect is connect to the internet I can
see if the nanny has shown up and
unlocked the doors you couldn't get in
Yeah right if my car is connected to the
Internet which it is I can take delivery
of a package into the trunk very
interesting right yeah so I mean it's
it's game-changing if I have a factory
in some faraway country and I want to
see what the quality situation is I can
monitor monitored remotely if there's a
fire in the building
I can remotely activate the fire
fighting equipment in a way that
optimizes the fire
as opposed to today which is you know
it's not really planned right I can have
robots going so it is a game changer so
what we do in the auto ID lab is we do
of course RFID research but we have it's
a amazing group of phd's PhD students
master students undergrads and a whole
bunch of companies it's about 15 people
in the lab and you know 50 people that
we worked with maybe a hundred you know
okay around the world and and then
that's just my lab Auto ID lab but then
there's another Auto IID lab from the
auto ID Center days you know taha ETH
Zurich there's one in these native
Cambridge and so on so if you add it all
up it's probably about a hundred people
nice and together we take on these big
problems of what is the future of the
Internet of Things how do autonomous
cars
how will they talk to stop signs right
that's IOT and questions emerge like
security
what if someone has interesting it's
likely that we'll have an IOT device
inside the stop sign rather they don't
rely on the camera of the vehicle look
house look how crazy it is right is a
higher efficacy to have the IOT sense
and it's safer look think about it in
the 21st century our self-driving Tesla
I come up to a stop I come up to a
traffic light
the Tesla looks at three circles and
says one of them I think is red so I'm
going to stop is that how it should work
or should it should good lights a dude
you better stop because I'm red right
now and even worse
you can spoof the light so there's a
cybersecurity problem so this unity put
cryptography and so I would he's gonna
provide everything that you yeah you're
thinking about these things well in
advance so that's so interesting so so
IOT inside of every stoplight the end
also a cryptographic secure signal that
occurs between them to prevent cyber
attacks very interesting he's inevitable
it's inevitable we have to do this
yeah and we're this is what my lab does
among other things
we in and then in order to power all of
these yeah how are we gonna have
everything everything in a factory all
the IOT sensors in a factory all the IOT
sensors on the traffic lights etc how
does that all give power it is that part
of the 5g network er
that's a great question the two aspects
to it the one is how do you network and
that's why fight you comes in ok ok and
one of the aspects of 5g is low latency
yeah why because if I'm coming up to a
traffic sign I need to know
instantaneously I need to stop it can
sort of you know have the the hourglass
and I'm waiting because the car's gonna
drive through the traffic crossing right
so that's where latency is very
important 5g will play a big part but
the other as where does the actual power
come from and that'll be a combination
if you can wire it it'll be wide but for
backup and in places you can't wire
it'll be scavenging that'll be RF
scavenging it'll be solar scavenging
there might be a little battery but to
store only between scavenging events so
one of the things we were working on for
example is building photovoltaics into
into IOT that's cool some people are
working on vibrational scavenging others
are working on RF scavenging so this
essentially would work as a massive
network of like the way that trees share
resources all underground is that and if
the ground battery if the normal
grounded battery fails then you can rely
on a photovoltaic and if and if that one
has a lot of energy and one doesn't they
can potentially pass along that energy
Wow
ok this is we could we will end up
having to spend more time talking about
Auto ID because this is cool industry
but I do want to also of course get to
all of the cool open learning stuff
that's going on so let's let's jump over
to that so um so teach us this was
actually really cool walking down the
hall and seeing that MIT OpenCourseWare
which was started in 2001 18 years of it
you're at you know 1.8 million
subscribers you have 2,500 courses this
is all free and this is into the this
isn't like MIT X EDX which has
lines and and whatnot this is totally
open flows of watching videos looking at
PDF notes etc so teach us about MIT
OpenCourseWare MITx and how that's like
EDX and and then yeah yeah sure sure
sure yeah so you know people don't
realize that the open source movement
for software oh yeah MIT is probably one
of the places that started and it's an
ethos it MIT which is let's when we do
stuff let's make it open
let's give knowledge away for free right
yeah your raise raising the baseline
around the world for access to these
really awareness expanding fields of
just access to them yeah yeah we've it's
our mission to people knowledge and to
give access ours too which is none none
of our content is ever paywall this is
all that amazing solution that's a nice
way to do a design of their way yeah and
your monitors in other ways right I mean
the you don't have to you monetize
everything just give stuff for free left
you know the tide lifts everyone and it
slice it was so we learned from other
states not like an MIT is getting
knowledge to the world the world gives
us knowledge we've learned from other
universities we learned from unknown
inventors in a you know in a part of the
world we never thought someone was being
so creative with it and so it's a very
mutual thing humanity is a beautiful
thing right okay so in 2000 2001 MIT
started looking at online education of
the first time and we said you know what
we aren't gonna make money with this we
will take our content professor by
professor course by course with their
permission and we'll just make it
available to the world for free and that
was called MIT OpenCourseWare and so now
they're actually way more than 2500
courses many of been archived but 2005
what 2000 funded courses today there you
can go to ocw.mit.edu anime oh yeah you
can read about I don't know quantum
mechanics or linguistics or mathematics
or cryptography or you know chemistry
it's it's a dazzling dazzling cabinet of
beautiful curiosities in the space of
knowledge and I'm so proud of MIT for
having done that so that was almost 20
years ago this reminds me so much of our
content as our content also features
these diverse leaders across fields and
then it gives you this multidisciplinary
lens of seeing the world if you go and
take these different courses watch these
different videos open learning okay yeah
so it's good sort of funny thing I was
actually on OpenCourseWare this morning
I was trying to help my daughter out
with something and I'd searched and if
coz when to open courseware and once you
get in it's like it's it's your stock
it's beautiful you know I read about
this heard about that I moved on to
something in math and then I did some
physics and you know I forgot about what
I was going to help my daughter with so
it's it's great stuff so that's how
OpenCourseWare is created the
OpenCourseWare is somewhat more static
it's still you know material with a few
you know and it's not getting dynamic
but in 2011 December mit announced to
the world that it would launch MOOCs and
so that was the creation of this thing
called MITx and EDX I'll explain the to
effectively what happened was in in
spring of 2012 Anant Agarwal a professor
at MIT a really amazing guy he launched
mi t--'s first MOOC this is one of the
first MOOCs in the world actually after
a couple of other universities and
athabasca university and there was a
MOOC from Stanford we did this MOOC so
on the same time and he ended up at some
but well in excess of a hundred thousand
students in his MOOC yeah many people at
the same time taking the course yeah Wow
and so so we knew we were onto something
so MIT and Harvard created a new
nonprofit entity called EDX and EDX is a
edx.org it's a destination as you know
true to form
EDX is open source all the Eric software
is open source it's been downloaded and
used thousands of times but people
around the world run their own sort of
mochi things and Eric's now has more
than 130 universities around the world
Caltech Dartmouth it's a McGill
but yeah you know serve Toronto IIT in
India Ching WA and China right so this
really amazing set of universities at
AHA in my friends at aha in in
Switzerland ETH Zurich they're all
members and each of them has a
production unit so MIT s mitx Harvard
and Harvard X Caltech escaped effects
they produce courses and EDX is the
platform on which these courses run so
students go to edx.org and they can see
this all the courses run by all the
universities and they can take them and
more recently Attucks launched which to
be launched and EDX took over something
called the micro masters which is a new
credential that we've invented
and most recently EDX also now on offers
full masters for masses of digitally be
free so the edx model is not free its
freemium so your knowledge you can get
the content for free you pay for the
certificates and ok and the content you
there's if if you if you're doing
assessments and you're getting a
certificate you pay for it but if you
just want to watch the videos that's
free yeah yeah interesting
whoa just democratizing our ability to
learn and then also even to get a
certificate oh yeah that's right and the
certificates you know we're problem but
tens of dollars hundred dollars don't
adult something that it's not like dang
well it's very cheesy wall as you as
you're speaking about the complexity and
from 2012 until now though these last
seven years of putting together the
different you listed like India and
China and Switzerland and then of course
Harvard and MIT and Dartmouth and stuff
how they are all able to how you guys
all work together in creating your own
MOOCs that go up into the EDX this seems
like a very complex endeavor as in like
it is Harvard at Harvard X's economics
course slightly different than MIT axis
economics course how does yeah yeah it's
the best way to build complex things is
to build simple things right okay so we
don't talk to each other well we produce
thing you know we produce an economics
course however produces it in on the
course economics course yeah
I could deform the perspectives are
different oh cool right so of course
does have different DNA like just like
people are similar but different we're
similar many respects are different in
different in many respects it's it's
fine and students sometimes will take
I've had students take the same course
from two different numerous universities
and say they're different in the
following ways and I learned something
then I learn something here
different perspectives it's great it's a
positive yeah and you're just that's it
that's also a good way to potentially
figure out what you can learn different
the different teaching styles at
different ear parts of the world
especially if you go across the world to
the western half a there versus a
eastern hemisphere and just see what how
the how its differently being taught
yeah okay
as we're talking about the complexity I
want you to teach us about this there's
this big air traffic control a big
bulletin in in open learnings floor here
and you have a list of of courses that
you are that you're updating or you're
publishing
out into the MIT X part of EDX and it
must be obviously very difficult to be
able to see you know you're trying to
you're trying to parse the world's
knowledge to find what can best fit into
your MITx course and then you're trying
to parse again to fit into this other
subject matter and then actually develop
out what the best educational curriculum
would be in that field so tell us about
how crazy this yeah it's a lot of fun
it's a little bit there's sort of it's
it's something between wonderfully
chaotic and somewhat organized right so
what we do is we have the the Dean for
digital learning who professor Krishna
rajagopal former chair of the faculty
his role within our orbit and my
organization is to go to faculty and say
hey why don't you propose courses and
they propose courses and then the
courses come to we have a review panel
and we say we'll produce this course
will produce that course and at 10:15
and then we produce them now the beauty
of that is you may get at the same time
in linguistics course being produced an
engineering course on IOT or something
and a course on drama yeah yeah it's
fascinating so for us it's extraordinary
learning experience right and we meet
these amazing colleagues talking about
this stuff so that's the sort of the
organized chaos part but then the organ
the more organized part comes because
sometimes departments will come to us
and say I want to produce a micro
masters in for example economics or in
manufacturing and and then you get a
sequence of courses on the same topic
but they're sort of more progressive but
to date we've produced so many courses
that are there lots of nice patterns you
can take a pathway in physics and take
the four key courses in physics or in
math or in yes in philosophy so so the
whole it's sort of like think of it this
way imagine if I had a jigsaw puzzle of
the Mona Lisa right and I randomly go
and put the picture of the the pieces up
and it should be like well what is that
if I she say you know I see the Mona
Lisa smile there are so the pictures in
there but I get what this is so that's
what's happening we're building an
online curriculum one jigsaw piece at a
time
and this is also important just to fir
to address the people that you know
you're a non-profit are the the other
harvardx and across the world these X's
that go into the EDX they're all
nonprofits well the we all say to you is
EDX of Shor's are nonprofit yes
so EDX is Arnold also open source or an
open source it's also open Scioscia mmm
funny me all the great universities in
the world most of them I think pretty
much all of them are nonprofits MIT
sahar nonprofit mm-hm EDX I mean Harvard
is a nonprofit Celtic is a non-profit
all nonprofits yeah so this is a
non-profit there's a great nonprofit
universities from around the world
working with a non-profit platform : X
and as long as you have an internet
connection boom go and start learn you
know and the the difference you know
with the Coursera type Coursera's
for-profit Khan Academy is doing more
high school level work now and I should
say we're very proud of Sal Khan because
he has a couple of degrees from MIT and
what he's done is extraordinary my 16
year old
learned a lot of stuff from Sal Khan so
that's high school he does stuff that
sort of bumps into college ap things
like that but he's really more school
oriented yeah I mean the baseline is
going up it's so cool to have them the
additional learning be free online it
that's mmm it's enabling the degrees of
freedom for people to explore what they
find most interesting more easily from
professionals from really high level
from around the world or you could say
the freedom of degrees the freedom of
degrees that's good yeah okay teach us
about the Jameel World Education lab
yeah so we at MIT spend a lot of time
thinking about the future of education
at MIT one of the things we do with our
MITx courses is we deploy them on campus
we flip the classroom professors then
have the opportunity to spend more time
coaching their students rather than you
know one-way lecturing because the
lectures now online and the student
might have watched the lecture on the
subway before coming into class or the
pre the previous evening and so the
actual classroom becomes much more
active and fun and engaging and much
more one-on-one so that's why we do this
and you know MIT is pretty cutting edge
our faculty are very you know sort of
forward-looking
with tech savvy so VR transforming
ourselves very well
so there's been a great deal of interest
from universities around the world but
also even companies governments like
national governments and also schools
like pry schools elementary schools
middle schools saying how do we upgrade
ourselves to the new pedagogy that our
students want and their parents want
because they're taking courses on Khan
Academy and they don't want to come sit
in a class passively while the teacher
just stalks how do we change it so due
to a generous gift from one of our
wonderful alumni how much Emil we
founded the Jameel World Education lab
and the J well as we call it and what it
is is an academy for academies that's
way to think about it
okay University for universities and so
what we have is a consortium of folks
interested in pre-kindergarten through
grade 12 education the pre-kindergarten
is important by the way yeah yeah
because kids start learning a lot the
moment they're born yes and you don't
even forget that out yes and then high
right which is you know colleges and
then also workforce education which is
our country entire countries are
grappling with how will people be
employed in the 21st century yes right
how will they learn yes and as I said
earlier all the time and that's gonna be
online so how do you rethink workforce
education you know the Germans have an
apprenticeship system yes the Swiss have
an apprenticeship system how do they fit
into all this
so to examine all that we have this
collaborative it's got three consortium
in the pre kindergarten through grade 12
higher ed and workforce training and
that's what the Jameel wood Education
lab is or as we call it affectionately a
well yeah having the discussions about
what is the best practices across all
the different ages and best strategies
like you were describing with
apprenticeships all that stuff because
mentoring is one of the best ways to be
able to learn that one-on-one absolutely
yes absolutely that's all be very
evolved to learn by mentorship because
we were all children and many of us will
become parents yeah it's a wonderful
form of mentorship yep and even what we
can't get from our family and relatives
we can get from mentors in industry and
that's right now they're places yeah so
what about the MIT integrated learning
initiative we have spent a lot of time
thinking about learning you know imagine
think of it this way
imagine medicine before we had x-rays in
biochemistry and genetics right before
World War II even before World War two
we didn't have we didn't have
antibiotics for one when Fleming
discovered penicillin but it was I think
it on World War two time a little bit
after after
yeah so now what we have is a very
fascinating thing in that we are
understanding how the brain learns
you're understanding where dyslexia and
ADHD come from you're understanding how
we forget and how important forgetting
is to learning how to stay high
neuroplasticity throughout that's right
yeah that's right
they're also it's amazing and this is
leading to other breakthroughs not just
in learning with leaning to the beating
that things like Alzheimer's epilepsy
etc etc you know Parkinson's disease and
you know degeneration and MIT has an
extraordinary punch of brain scientists
literally brain scientists they're also
learning or the economics of learning
you know so all these emotional debates
today in politics about is our charter
schools good or not but how about we
burden the emotional debates with the
actual facts and data yes right yes
there's amazing amounts of data
yes you know there's a lottery system
work what's the best transportation type
system how should you incentivize
teachers so it's a very amazing approach
and so the MIT integrated learning
initiative
uses science numbers data economic
thinking economics econometrics to
figure out how to reinvent education
based on these fundamental discoveries
about how we learn interesting and what
have been some of the key analyses of
neuroscience as well as economics and
what have they taught us so far well
they've taught is is surprisingly human
I was worried that when we the
discoveries would be you know sort of
cold you know clinical but actually the
discoveries been very human one of them
is that humans are learning patterns
makes sense we've evolved to learn just
as children to learn from adults even
adults learn the same way by the way
right so coaching interpersonal coaching
works very well we know for example
about the importance of things like
forgetting we know for example how
dyslexia occurs we know and we are now
understand ADHD we understand how that
happens we know how to detect dyslexia
we know for example the importance of
working with your hands
it's fascinating yeah you actually if
you do something in your hands we'll
learn it better yes we are know the
importance of curiosity was actually
fascinating there's research that shows
we learn better if you're curious so if
the teacher did nothing more than make
the student curious nothing more they
would do a lot better sometimes then
what we do today yet right because it
they can light their own fire under
their own butt to go learn keep learn
curiosity releases dopamine which is a
neurotransmitter and just as hunger
releases so I like curiosity releases
dopamine very cool and once the that
circuit is activated you learn better so
it's actually fascinating and this is
very human any parent knows some of the
stuff and it's sort of you know
confirming that we also know for example
that you can only learn for about five
ten minutes before your brain sort of
fills up and then you should do it use
it to all interesting but all the
lectures are an hour whoa okay so it's a
kind of piece of learning and then
hands-on and they mean peace baby so
learning and then actually hands-on or
test the person as the person here to
retain did proves intentions for the
testing effect lots written about it
that's why all EDX courses most EDX
courses we try and make our videos mitx
courses ten minutes hmm
so interesting because these these
interviews are long-form so it could be
potentially interesting to occasionally
pause or take notes while you're going
through it and then try and review what
you're learning throughout the
conversations have conversations with
other people about you've been learning
that's why we talk about the community
below in the comment section and on the
public telegram that we have going by
the way one of the advantages of online
is you can post you can pause the live
lecturer yeah yeah that's right
imagine if you just pause the live
lecture you can do that yes yes which
this is kind of what this as uni as we
need that's right when you're watching
the content totally I was also just I
was myself starting to salivate at the
at the beauty of of what it feels like
to to seed that curiosity in new minds
into the war
that's uh you can see it in the eyes of
the curious ones and I hope you see
later than my tía and MIT I feel like
you can smell and feel the curiosity
totally it sizzles with curiosity
yeah this Cambridge area is it's like
the East Coast Silicon Valley that's
definitely how it feels like if you
think of Silicon Valley as a West Coast
camera that's good I'll go back and tell
them what I get back is that we're the
west coast Cambridge okay tell us about
what you're seeing because you mentioned
this earlier I think it's super
important to address this automations
permeating into every single industry
artificial intelligences Internet of
Things is so what's going on with the
future of human capital what is it
important for us to pass along to
children that are being born into the
world now like where should they be
focus their attention worship parents be
helping kids focus their attention on
you know the old song whatever you can
do I can do better my version of my not
mine is a well-known nerdy version of
that is whatever you can do I can do
meta okay so I think what we need to do
is teach our children to become learning
machines because they will learn for the
rest of their lives I hope they're
already teaching our children for
example to exercise and stay fit listen
Eliza don't smoke right
a similar habit is equivalent exercises
learn you will always learn you will
always need to learn it's fun keeps you
engaged it'll delay old age but more
importantly you will be alive and
employed and more prosperous if you
learn all the time if there's one thing
I would say it is teach them the
importance of learning and how to learn
that's that's really profound and you're
so right and if we if we dig at
different areas around the edge of
knowledge and get that those
multidisciplinary connections around how
the world works we will stay employed
longer people will want to surround
themselves with us because they'll see
the way that we meta we have an abstract
perspective on how things work in the
world and also if we can dig into the
nuance of how things work as well but
learning defined broadly which is not
just listening but doing you know but
doing doing so I mean it's everything
you have to have a growth mindset where
you're learning you're improving you're
growing in some direction but you're
constantly added that's gotta be a
fixation I love it oh that's such a good
piece of advice and then and then give
me give me your one principle for that
lifelong learning well is that as people
know okay I should go towards healthier
eating I should go away from smoking I
should go towards exercising what would
be the go towards learning where would
you do it remember the dose at kiss add
the most interesting around the world
all right oh my gosh yeah he has a
lining sit stay curious my friend yeah
yeah that's a way for phone line stay
curious my friend if you if we can
Kindle curiosity make a state of being
hopefully somewhat directed towards
where it'll help you with life but just
generally you because you can't control
it that would be my first and that's the
most important principle and again we
make that conscious choice not only to
seed that curiosity in the youth but
then to also help make sure we don't
build distractive systems that take them
away from curiosity but that rather
inspire that curiosity with that sort of
a potentially an artificial intelligence
that walks helps you oh you're
interested in these fields here's all
these interesting online courses and
hands-on experiences that you can
explore in that field for the next
couple of months and yeah things like
you know if you look at our economy one
of my an MIT student told me we are
heading to an economy that is sort of an
intentional economy where like clickbait
it's trying to attract your attention
and then you can read more about some
you know
Hollywood couple and their antics so
we're if we can point our attention if
curiosity claimed our attention but
healthy curiosity as opposed to
clickbait which is sort of unhealthy
curiosity that's gonna be a battle it's
the same as junk food versus eating good
food right it's this is our battle in
the 21st century very cool there's
there's a junk food for the attention
and then there's a healthy food for the
intention attention yeah that's you need
to have intention to point the attention
in the right place and they will the
systems you know whether it's an ad on a
website or some clickbait as I said or
it's all about grabbing your attention
stay curious my friends and and and do a
good job at at parsing all of the
information that is arising because you
can find signal sometimes 80% of what
you need to know is in just 20% of
what's available that Pareto principle
and so if you can find that 20% and not
stay away from the other distractive
information okay couple quick thoughts
on the way out okay
what would you say because you've now
passed long staying curious to other
people having their attention to the
healthy attention for themselves what
about for you what has been a core
driving principle in your own
development through
I mean it's curiosity actually I didn't
articulate it earlier right
I think it's curiosity it's and you know
in this day and age you know we have all
sorts of expressions inhibiting
curiosity why do we tell kids curiosity
killed the cat
right all good things come to those who
wait because we couldn't deal with the
curiosity the curious kid became an
irritant right but now the curious kids
gonna win there's a you know there's a
term in the Bible right the meek shall
inherit the earth sort of my version of
that is the geek shall inherit the way
yeah so curious kids I think looking
back I was just curious and a lot of my
the people are hang out with my friends
or curious and I enjoy our shared
curiosity
you know it can even be as simple as
becoming a good question asker yes
amongst other people when you are
passing time is asked thought-provoking
questions probe reality with
thought-provoking questions yeah
oh and once you get knowledge integrated
and apply it connect the dots that's the
second thing you need to do and then
third is applied yeah don't just be a
passive consumer do something with it
yes yes sounds so good okay would this
wouldn't be simulation if we didn't ask
you do you think this is a simulation
you think this is a simulation you know
sort of heavily if you've seen the movie
matrix it's based actually on one
version of Hindu mythology yes really no
okay
and all Hindu philosophy actually is
this a simulation I don't think we'll
ever know what is the Hindu well I mean
they basic idea you know is it's the
Maya you know I don't know if you're
really here right and that question is
asked and the matrix picks up on that
yeah yeah is it a similar scene I'm not
sure it could be but hey I'm enjoying it
so this is I think you see in it this is
several thousand years then old this is
not a very whoa yeah cool yeah so it's
still Maya they call it Maya which means
magic Maya it's because someone has
commented before oh that's that's such a
recent phenomenon people talking about
this that's cool that Maya has been
around that long
okay and last question that we like to
ask our guests is what do you think the
most beautiful thing in the world I
think it's human beings its nature
actually on human beings being of cause
we might be destroying nature but being
an outcrop of nature I think that our
existence is natural and there's
something tremendous about nature and
human beings you know I think that is
what it is and if it's assimilation is
that keeping it place yeah asaji has
done the the levelling up in
and maxing out of his open learning
attributes the attributes what's next
yeah yeah yes keep up keep leveling up
everyone keep me leveling up Sanjay
pleasure pleasure thank you so much
thank you thank you yes and and thank
you everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear from
you in the comments below go and check
out the links below but to edx.org and
also to the MIT OpenCourseWare and go
and build the future as we talked about
stay curious also go and build get your
hands on go and play I find that healthy
food go and find the healthy food and
support us so we can continue going to
great locations like this and having
these powerful conversations and sharing
them with you much love to you all go
and build the future talk to you soon
thank you